rogers in houston texas
hey roger how are you doing great dave
how you doing today
better than i deserve how can ken and i
help
well i've listened to your show for a
while now and uh i really
respect your opinion when it comes to uh
parenting advice and i feel like
uh my wife and i have kind of backed
ourselves into a corner with our
daughter
i was hoping maybe you could give me a
different perspective
on how to deal with her okay and
what's going on well
she graduated high school a few years
ago and decided she was going to go off
to college and
we supported her decision and she moved
off and when she came back
um through some series of unfortunate
events
um we have a beautiful little
granddaughter
now and um
now we're trying to coach her
and i think we're running into that
situation where
a person has to want to be coached in
order
for things to kind of take hold if you
will
so she's she's uh uh passive or she's
rebellious
uh more on the passive side i would say
how old is she
she's 21. how's the baby
she is one she will be two next week
wonderful
that's so wonderful what are you
coaching her to do what is the specific
coaching that she's not receiving
well some of the lessons that uh
we have just recently learned in the in
the past a few years
of you know managing money and trying to
get your future going together and
and uh get some kind of structure
underneath you so that you can become
self-sufficient and and move on with
your life
yep is she working
not currently um we have
well we currently have another little
one on the way that is
slated to be here uh in the next three
or four weeks actually
she's pregnant with her second correct
okay
and where's the father for this one
this one is here they're both living in
our house
the agreement was that they would stay
here and try to save up some money to
get their own place
and they were planning to get buried in
august
we had a talk with them last week see
how they were doing
and none of that
has come to fruition okay
well here's the thing these are kids
having kids
and uh
your your heart is broken and you want
to be kind
to your own kid and yet you realize that
this is not going anywhere
so my tendency
tempered by my wife is to move too
quickly and too
deliberately and then sharon adds some
soft edges to that and we usually come
into a good balance we often say
our kids turned out because of the fear
of their father and the nurturing of
their mother
so we know this about ourselves and so
we're good with that
as a matter of fact it works with the
grand babies too we're working the same
system with them
and uh we have a good guy good cop bad
cop routine and it works pretty well
but uh grand babies love papa dave too
but papa dave don't play
so uh if i tell you do something i don't
tell you three times
you just freaking do it so uh it's old
school it's an integrity thing no is a
complete sentence so anyway
this is who you're talking to and asking
about this
all right and so uh you know and then i
have to go
okay i gotta be i gotta be gentle and i
need to be kind
and i need to give some space um
obviously
what i think i would do is just sit down
and dream with them and say
guys the way this is all unraveling
it doesn't feel like you're ever going
to become somebody
so you need to you need to sit down you
cannot stay here any longer unless we
get on a
program to help you win at your life
i'm not going to participate in you
being a turtle without a shell
useless and passive and so because i
love you too much for that to happen so
young man young lady what are you going
to be when you're 30
and how are we going to help you get
there and
we call that as goal setting a desired
future
what is your desired future and then you
start asking yourself what has to be
true
to get to that desired future and then
you can say okay
now we have laid out a game plan
together i want to be a nurse i want to
be an
auto mechanic i want to do this this is
how i'm going to feed these two children
and be a good mom and a good dad okay
now i will tell you as your dad who
loves you more than life itself
that i think there's a couple of things
you're going to start doing now you can
do whatever you want to do but this is
what would happen if it was my house
okay we're going to put in place a plan
and you can stay here
until x date as a part of that plan
if you are executing on the plan
that is your rent you have to pay rent
you have to execute the steps in the
plan
or you have to leave now that means
you're going to get married this weekend
and that means at our house we're not
doing substance abuse
that means that our house on sundays we
go to church
that means that our house we're going to
grow spiritually we're going to take
care of our bodies physically
we're going to start in behaving in
moral ways
we're going to start doing these things
it's not shaming someone these are the
elements that will cause you to win when
you're 30 and i'm going to help you get
there
if you refuse to take those steps
then it is immediately an eviction
notice for you
because i love you and i will not
participate in you
losing i will only participate in you
winning i don't know ken
well i think dave's giving you a really
good path
on boundaries i would add to this that
as
as a father and and your wife as the
mother
you need to stop getting out of the
motivation game you're trying to
motivate them and you cannot motivate
another person don't put a situation in
place where they need to do it well but
i want yes but
i'm dave's right i'm going to give you
one thing i think i would add to that
i think you have to have a sit down with
both of might start with your daughter
because she's your daughter and i would
get into
what's causing her to act the way she is
and what i mean by that is motivation so
there's a motive behind everything
it's called intrinsic motivation and i
would just simply say this
she has got to see along with dave's
plan and the desired future
she's got to be able to look at what's
causing her
to stay in the pit that she's in right
now she's created a little bit of a pit
and it's either fear uh and so that's
motivating her now and let's get to the
optimistic side of what motivates her
and you as her
parents you've known this kid your whole
life
what has driven her when she's been in
seasons of life
where she's really on fire and active
and i would bring that discussion
to the part where dave said what's that
desired future look like
and if you can help them see that
motivation where they begin to see worth
and they begin to see a positive future
despite some of the missteps
that's going to give you the best chance
to combine the boundaries
and get some positive movement yeah the
essence of this what i'm saying is where
there is no vision that people
perish that's right she needs a vision
he needs a vision
they need a vision and you're going to
help them develop one
and make sure they execute to get there
and part of that is within six months
they're gone
because they're starting to take the
steps to get there